c'est donc elisabeth bornes qui a été
nommé hier à matignon et je vous propose
qu'on évacue d'emblée toutes les blagues
musicale c'est dommage parce qu'elles
sont pas mal quand même
[Musique]
c'était
vous salue l'arrivée du nouveau premier
ministre vous l'avez nouveau premier
ministre voudrait pas première ministre
c'est moche non enfin à l'hôtel aux
règles moi vous savez le français pour
moi ça va d'abord être bon donc oui
c'est le nouveau premier ministre
pourrait dire première ministre bien sûr
on doit dire ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui a changé
dans les années récentes à l'époque de
d'edith cresson donc 1991 92 c'était
premier ministre donc les choses ont
changé maintenant dans les dictionnaires
disent tous première ministre madame le
premier ministre ne serait pas fautif
non plus c'est juste plus dans l' usage
en fait c'est en train de sortir de l'
usage voilà faudrait qu'on se mettre
tout de suite d'accord de qui on parle
qu'on soit tous raccord quand on dit
elisabeth borne à partir de maintenant
on ne parlera que de sept personnes de
notre nouvelle première ministre voilà
et pas de l'autre
[Musique]
parce qu'elle aussi s'appelle elisabeth
bornes c'est une chanteuse espagnole
ancienne miss tarragona c'est un
homonyme la même orthographe
on peut s'interroger pourquoi on a
attendu si longtemps pour nommer une
femme est aujourd'hui parce que c'est
que c'est une femme quand madame bornes
c'est bien autre chose
avec une très grande expérience avec
beaucoup de qualificatifs pourquoi tu as
accepté de venir parce que tu sais très
bien qu'on va pas te laisser comme ça là
je cherche un travail je coupais c'est
un peu compliqué avec nous tu veux pas
aller postuler comme ça c'était ça le
problème
s'excuse mois mais qu'est ce que tu veux
faire dans la vie
pour combien d'argent les français sont
prêts à lécher la barre du métro plus ou
moins de 30000 euros on a posé cette
question pour me déposer personnellement
un peu le fait pour 30000 ya pas de
piège je vous ramène pas une barre de
métro dans 2000
je vous jure qu a pas de piège vous le
faites pour combien vous après ou avant
coheed
[Rires]
elle était posée
en tout cas moi je le fais un joli
direct le principe du barathon des vins
comme son nom l'indiqué ces deux
coureurs 42 km tout en goûtant des 20
régions à chaque ravitaillement et alors
comme si ce n'était pas déjà assez
compliqué en plus il faut faire tout ça
déguisé c'est fait maison ça non
comme vous voyez ça
super héros de guyane
iron man
mois pour 30 mille vaches se fait toute
l'année
pour 30000 euros je fais tout va mieux
je fais les sièges et toi
ça dépend de la ligne alors moi je fais
grave dix ans
la première personne qu'il faut aimer
c'est soi même si on a une idée d'offrir
quelque chose à l'autre qui est valable
c'est à dire chez les femmes c'est quand
même le pouvoir de séduction et chez les
hommes c'est cette fichue direction qui
leur complique l'existence quand même
pas parce qu'ils imaginent que tout
résident l'attend non accord bientôt on
va jusqu'au ouais c'est un handicap vous
avez volé donc nous sommes davantage
chez nous les femmes mais il faut les
convaincre du contraire laquelle est la
plus longue
c'est moi
il a parlé de sa baguette magique merci
il était mal placé
allez-y vite s'il vous plaît
en fait je t'aime depuis le premier jour
depuis le 15 août 2018 vont se
rencontrer alors 1 julie loïse rosalie
des bois c'est ce que tu veux
je pense que je pensais que les médias
ce que tu veux
je t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime
le
j'étais que je t'aime que je t'aime
que je t'aime que je t'aime que je
t'aime
je te quelque chose et elle quand je
de marché je vais tenter le coup mais
aussi vous dévore le prix low rider
haggard
je n'ai jamais eu l'occasion de vous
lire mais voilà est-ce que ne seriez
éventuellement d'accord pour m'épouser
un peu parce que tout le monde dit oui
bah écoute et peut-être les gars mais
j'suis pas qu'on en parle pas en direct
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui se passe je suis fort
précis et désolé je sais je vous le
traitez très très très vite après bon
j'ai une excuse mais je sais qu'elle est
pas valable je suis content ce soir
daniel mas votre permis